we will move into our first panel
discussion taking up the theme that
David is raised and the question of what
is scientific truth so if I can invite
our panelists on stage please Peter
Doherty Helga Novotny and Joseph
Stiglitz please Joe at the end he'll
give if you go in the middle there
please I'm testing let me pour your
waters so as you'll see from your
program the Nobel week dialogue is very
much about this sort of discussion and
the day is mostly devoted to
conversations between varying groups of
participants and this topic of
scientific truth is one that we'll
revisit in various forms throughout the
day we'll be talking about uncertainty
and trust and evidence in panels later
on but for now we just have a few
minutes to talk about what scientific
truth is and perhaps to respond a little
I think we've we're done thank you
perhaps to respond a little to david's
talk so Peter David is of course a
theoretical physicist you are a
biologist do you have any different view
perhaps of scientific truth well not
really I mean
David's exposition was great because
what it brings it back to his reality I
mean what we're trying to do is deal
with reality and understand reality and
reality is real there's no doubt about
that as a biomedical scientists I'm
interested in basically climate disease
and death person a very careful position
to be in I work on infection and
immunity I'm concerned with cancer and
the realities are there if you've got
colon cancer it's a reality if you've
got melanoma it's a reality if you have
pancreatic cancer to reality and you'll
soon be dead so we understand that truth
is not a word
we use in 50 years as a biomedical
science I've never stood up in front of
an audience and said the truth is what I
say is our best understanding is that
now our what the data tells us is that
now through that process that David
discussed which is the process of
particularly in biomedical science not
so much big theory as you have in
physics because you have the laws of
physics
biology is beset by evolution and
evolution is a process where as as the
creatures have become more complex we've
built on pre-existing structures so it's
like an old house in gottenberg that's
built in the 16th century and in the
20th century you have to install
plumbing I mean you're not doing it the
ideal way if we did it the ideal way
we'd have four hearts so we don't die of
a heart attack okay but we don't do it
that way so so basically what we try to
understand is that underlying reality of
this particular situation and often what
we get to in science in biomedical
science through experimentation through
testing often through rather ad hoc type
testing of light with no great
theoretical concept behind it is a
solution or what looks like a possible
solution and the solution is whether you
live or you die and that's a pretty good
solution for most of us and we don't
have a lot of quarrels with that even
mr. Trump doesn't quarrel with the idea
of being live or dead I don't want to
expand on that but basically often when
we get a solution we we don't we don't
fully understand what's happening when
we move on mm-hmm because that problem
is no longer imaginary for us so that's
that's a kind of a bit different from
the physicist who's got an overarching
theory and of course in the end
everything comes back to the laws of
physics
so beautified I hesitate to stop you but
um so you're right scientists may not
use the term truth but the people but
people out there do all the time and
they equate scientific reality with
scientific fact and they want to hold on
to scientific fact Helder Helga what's
the relationship but
in fact and truth in science well allow
me to bring in perhaps a European
perspective because we have heard very
much about Donald Trump and of course he
also has an impact on what happens in
the rest of the world but from a
European perspective I was struck by the
fact that in the American discourse by
and large you speak about post rose and
in Europe we speak about post faction
and there is a slight difference now
truth and facts are not the same I think
we agree on that and it may have to do
with the fact that you have creationism
in the u.s. you have very little
creationism in Europe not worth to speak
of you have many more evangelicals while
you're by and large things of itself and
is a much more secular continent and
therefore I think we have to look also
at the relationship between science and
democracy and what people at least in
Europe in this post factual age are
questioning is and we have seen it in
Britain we see it in many other parts is
scientists are seen as being part of the
establishment and part of the elite now
we are part of the elites there's no
question about it but I think we have to
not to be over defensive now we have to
stand up you know and defend rose by
saying every time this is scientific
truth I think we have to understand what
people are really protesting against why
they feel left behind and so on and it
is not that they are questioning I mean
there are some and I think they are
mainly in the US there are some that
question scientific choice but by and
large people want to dispute facts
because they do not fit the context in
which they live
and part of the answer to David's very
relevant question how can we stand up to
it I think has to do with trying to make
a sense of facts and put them into
context that people understand the
context and can relate to the context I
know this will not solve all problems
there is always a minority that will
continue liars can cannot be convinced
by any argument we know all that but I
think one way forward would really be
how can we bring science and democracy
again closer together because I think
David is fully right science and
democracies are allies and without
science democracy will not progress at
all and science needs democracy as a way
to hold up the very strong belief in the
freedom of inquiry without that belief
and this is something that society must
support and stand behind it science will
also be hampered thank you Joe do you
want to come well I'm an economist with
social science which is some people
don't really think it's a science at all
we but we have a problem that is
actually much worse than what you
described because there are many people
who are motivated not to believe the
truth so it's you liked a good if if
you're the Koch brothers and you have a
lot of investments in coal you have an
incentive not to believe in climate
change and you have an incentive to try
to convince all Americans that climate
change is not real it's an inconvenient
truth but it's also a very costly truth
so there has been a wholesale assault on
our institutions of science and this has
been compounded by two other factors
going in one is the role of ideology
that
that at the core of economics is a
belief does the market work and that's
very ideological and those who want to
believe in free market do not want to
look at evidence that's contrary to that
so you have a strong ideology a little
bit like the evolutionary ideology and
in the United States there's a
particular problem a very large fraction
of Americans still do not believe in
evolution just like they don't believe
in climate science so you have to
overcome this ideology and finally there
is this populism today in the United
States where you want to use that word
this notion that a large fraction of
Americans have been left behind and they
associate that with an establishment
next you know what you said and they
associate that establishment with a
belief in these truth institutions
universities and a majority of the
Republican Party in surveys think that
universities are a bad thing yeah now
when you have a majority of one of the
two parties thinking that the
institutions of knowledge are
undermining Society and our bad thing
you have a problem as a society so
that's fast I do yes please for quickly
good so Joe you know what seems to me to
drive the American dynamic more than any
other thing I mean obviously there's a
bad actors who are you know like the
Koch brothers because of its a financial
interest but really it seems to me that
the thing that is most critical is the
belief system there no tax no regulation
free market economies and that basically
if you're going to do something about
climate change firstly you need taxes
and secondly you need regulation and
this is why it is so deeply threatening
to the to the basic business American
psyche and that to me is a religion and
almost immune to evidence
so right now we've been through this big
thing about tax cuts people appeal to
supply-side measures that this will
stimulate the economy we had an
experiment not a controlled experiment
in the way that we were talking about
earlier today but you might say an
experiment under Reagan where we lower
taxes there were predictions made what
would happen both of the macro-level
what would happen to GDP at the micro
level in terms of savings and labor
supply all those predictions were
refuted and yet after all the evidence
comes in they the same arguments are
brought out and you say how could they
do that and it comes to a religion where
it can't be refuted yes
you know and here reality comes back in
again reality will also hit this kind of
religion social reality economic reality
the global reality of the world we live
in with all its interconnected financial
streams etc at one point it takes time
but at one point it will hit back yeah I
I hate to be a pessimist because my life
has been about optimism and change but
we had the reality of the 2008-2009
crisis I mean that you couldn't have
more reality than that and yet the large
number of particularly macro economists
who believe in the same models that
brought us this crisis that has not
changed that religion has been dented
but not fundamentally changed some of
the sign find things about economist
it's very interesting I think it's kind
of an attack on science and but also I
think there's an assumption within that
whole establishment that science will
solve the issue will solve the problem
that's what's expected a medical science
you don't get much problem getting
Republicans for instance to support
biomedical research they're all pretty
stupid and they want to live forever
okay
basically and so that that's not an
issue that they're not really against
science they're against science which is
inconvenient then but the question I
posed to them is you know we are
enormous ly clever about science we have
a tremendous people tremendous
intellects you've heard one of them
earlier and of course the philosopher
Lee who is a salmon yes wonderful
but when it's the last time that we made
it rain and when it's the last time that
we made it stop raining and I think
that's where we should start we are
relatively powerless in the foursome and
face of nature there's actually more of
an anti-science deep in the in the
conservative movement they don't want
the collection of data that might
counter their beliefs so they've
actually been trying to suppress science
and the most important thing was one of
the things that was emphasized this
morning which is knowledge is tentative
and the scientific knowledge is is
tentative and they're trying I thought
David put it very well we're competing
with Liars who are selling the notion of
false confidence in the truth and we're
trying to explain that there is
uncertainty but there are certain things
that we know are true that climate
change is very very very likely okay if
the time if the time keeper lets it go
everything falls apart right last word
to your opponent Russell he said the
problem with the world is only fanatics
and fundamentalists are always certain
wise people have doubts thank you
perfect
[Applause]
[Music]